mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
suppose a square contains a semi-circle
and a quarter circle as shown
the semi-circle and quarter-circle are
tangent to each other
suppose the semi-circle has a diameter
equal to 12 and the quarter circle has a
radius equal to 12.
there are two parts to the question
first what is the area of the square
second construct the tangent line
segment a b
what is the length of a b equal to
this problem is adapted from one by at c
share 41 on twitter
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall that if two circles are tangent
their centers and the tangent point are
collinear
that's because each radius will be
perpendicular to the tangent line
therefore atb will be a straight line
segment
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
so now let's solve the problem
we'll first construct the center of the
semicircle the center of the quarter
circle and the tangent point
these three points will be collinear so
we can construct a line segment between
them
then the semicircle has a radius that's
equal to one-half of twelve which is
equal to six
we can then get the dimensions of this
line segment it will be the radius of
the semicircle and the radius of the
quarter circle
let's now focus on just this right
triangle
suppose the remaining dimension on the
side of the square is equal to x
that means the side of the square has a
length equal to 12 plus x
so the other side will also have a
distance that's equal to x
we can then solve for each side of this
right triangle
the hypotenuse will be equal to 6 plus
12 which is equal to 18.
one leg will be equal to 6 plus x and
the other leg will be equal to 12 plus x
we will then focus on just this right
triangle
because we have a right triangle we have
six plus x squared plus 12 plus x
squared is equal to 18 squared
we can then systematically solve this
equation for x
we will use the quadratic formula and
we'll get two possibilities
either x is equal to negative nine plus
three times the square root of 17 or x
is equal to negative 9 minus 3 times the
square root of 17.
but recall that x is a length so it
should be positive so we will eliminate
this negative value
we thus get a value for x
we can substitute it into this side of
the triangle
we will simplify this to solve for the
side of the triangle
recall that this side of the triangle is
also the side of the square so we can
get the area of the square by squaring
this length
we can simplify this and it will be
equal to 162
plus 18 times the square root of 17
which is approximately equal to 236
and that's part one of the question
let's now solve part two
we need to solve for the length of a b
to get started the tangent line a b is
perpendicular to the radius of the
quarter circle and the radius of the
semicircle
we'll then focus on this right triangle
suppose one angle is equal to alpha and
the other angle is equal to beta
now consider this right triangle
since one angle is equal to alpha the
other angle will be equal to beta
now from the point a construct a
horizontal perpendicular line segment
we have another right triangle here
where one of its angles is equal to beta
so the other angle will be equal to
alpha
now compare this right triangle with
this right triangle
what can we say about them
well these two right triangles have the
same measures of their angles we have
alpha and beta and each of them has a
longer leg that's equal to the side of
the square
therefore this blue triangle is
congruent to this green triangle
so their hypotenuse lengths will be
equal to each other
we know that the length of the
hypotenuse on the green triangle is
equal to 6 plus 12.
therefore a b will also be equal to 6
plus 12 which is equal to 18
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]